remember the BMX craze back in the 1980s
and bicycle motocross is still popular
among young people today
remix phones BMX started out on dirt
tracks explains our man with the moves
Andre but the scene has moved on with
BMX fans taking over cities and trading
dirt tracks for neat and tidy halfpipes
off-roaders have gone through a similar
transformation they're now called SUVs
and a growing number of drivers now buy
them chiefly for the city let's see if
this baby is cross country compatible
before going urban the tiguan certainly
looks like it's equipped with off-road
routes and you feel it too it's
primarily powered by the front wheels
but with any loss of traction the
vehicle immediately switches to 4motion
all-wheel drive
back here is it not release from all
that hill looks rather intimidating
dandre but with a bit of a run up the
Tigger one has no problem getting right
up where it belongs come on yo loco who
among the optional extras is a special
off-road front-end package that raises
the approach angle and a handy feature
for spotting obstacles the driver may
not be able to see is the camera with
all-round visibility Andre takes this
little challenge nice and slow due to
the limited spring travel we're not in a
hurry you can tackle a flight of stairs
with the tagline ultimate didn t go on
mine a tough one tough on but that's
enough of the off-road action we've
provided Andre with a nice clean silver
colored t go on for the city this one
doesn't have the optional off-road front
section the new T go on is the first of
its kind to be built on the modular
transverse matrix architecture and it
has a long wheelbase with short
overhangs laundry switches cars before
heading off to downtown Berlin
the modular transverse setup has
benefits that the tigga want also
profits from in addition to lower
development costs it also reduces the
vehicles weight while increasing
efficiency the version we tested is
powered by a 2-liter TDI engine with 110
kilowatts of output and a fuel economy
of 5.7 liters per 100 kilometers
Volkswagen wants to use the tigga wons
genes to create an entire product family
its members will include a longer
version for overseas markets and a
crossover lifestyle model
as if SB 21 in there we're really
surprised Andre was how comfortable it
is around town with most other SUVs he's
driven he felt the suspension was too
harsh but not the t go on it has a very
balanced ride and you can always use the
drive mode switch and dynamic chassis
control to shift into comfort mode and
then really cruise along smoothly
mistystar him glide and owner own fish
problema that's one of the major pluses
of modern SUVs they're highly versatile
and combine off-road abilities with
sound drivability on the road
open de Tigre tigga one might not have
made Andre an immediate SUV convert but
he's pleasantly surprised by its
off-road performance and it's smooth
ride on city streets so if you're into
SUVs he definitely recommend the t go on
the new t go on cells were just under
twenty six thousand euros in Germany the
version Andre testing costs around
40,000 bosma's on Madonna what qualities
does a modern subcompact need to have of
course it has to be small says car
tested i know the Opel Carl is so small
it barely takes up half a normal parking
space a subcompact should also be modern
and the coral is the only model in its
class with personal online and service
assists the system goes by the name
OnStar it offers a wide range of safety
and comfort features for example if a
collision triggers the airbag the system
automatically contacts the OnStar
service center which asks whether you
need help if you don't answer the center
immediately contacts local emergency
services
opals entry-level model was launched at
the end of 2014 the Carl maybe opal
smallest car but it doesn't have to hide
behind its Big Brother's backs the price
is very attractive the basic version
costs 9,500 euros in Germany and even
this version has the standard
infotainment system
we tested the 1-liter 3-cylinder
gasoline engine version which produces
55 kilowatts and can take the car up to
170 km/h average fuel consumption is
under 5 litres per 100 kilometers all of
the carls components have been designed
to minimize vibration and sound that
starts with the low resonance engine
block and continues with the split oil
pan the exhaust manifold which is
integrated in the cylinder head and
additional acoustic insulation on the
cam covers opal design the 1-liter
3-cylinder engine especially for the
carl it's powerful enough for urban
traffic or country roads as reinhold the
Carl has a surprisingly long list of
extras LED daytime running lights a lane
departure alert and for cold winters a
heatable leather steering wheel but the
latter is not standard it's part of the
comfort package which also offers a
parking assistant heated seats opal
charges 395 euros for the package the
seats in the top equipment version
innovation are made of a combination of
fabric and imitation leather
starting with the middle variant edition
d Carl has a city driving mode press a
button and maneuvering in city traffic
gets a lot simpler the technology
previously featured in opals Adam and
corsa models the Carl has nice handling
to partly thanks to the cleverly
designed macpherson struts on the front
axle the springs are specially shaped to
partially compensate lateral forces this
engages the shock absorbers more
smoothly and also with less wear so they
have a longer operational life the Carl
styling also shows that opal is trying
to shed its Doughty image the best thing
about a subcompact for Reinhold is when
it doesn't feel small and the Carl has
enough room to transport five people
comfortably plus you have the perky
1-liter 3-cylinder engine and the state
of the art assists and safety systems
see how it's a steamer
BMW is adding a new version of its
compact I three electric car with
batteries that store much more power
they increase the cars range by more
than fifty percent up from 190
kilometers to 300 kilometers on a single
charge even in everyday use with air
conditioning or heating the car maker
says the battery will take you 200
kilometers before needing a recharge
Audi has given its popular a3 model a
facelift among the most important
changes are improved connectivity
morris's systems new engines and a
slightly modified appearance the new a3
comes in a 3-door version as a sport
back a sedan or a convertible prices for
the new a3 started twenty three thousand
three hundred euros in Germany
as the camping season begins the camper
manufacture heimer presents a new
interpretation of a classic the heimer
mobile b-class dynamic line miss Cooper
vixen don't confuse this with the
b-class from Mercedes says cart estimate
is correct the mobile home is something
entirely different than high murs
b-class has been around a lot longer the
first timer be class caravan appeared in
1981 on a mercedes-benz chassis the
latest generation on a Fiat chassis is a
prime example of lightweight
construction montes reminds us that a
mobile home needs a shower and a toilet
the space the high Merlotte's them may
be small but it certainly does the job
the shower door even closes tightly so
you don't get the toilet wet when you
shower door shuts knocking doors and
after your shower the refrigerator is
right there for a quick nightcap before
bed in this model with this wheelbase
there are two beds in the rear or you
can take a rest in the front above the
driver's cab
then either bed above the driver's cab
moves up or down electrically at the
push of a button and alameda hoof on
Connor a big problem for caravans is
weight and Germany if you received a
driver's license for passenger cars
after 1999 you can drive vehicles
weighing up to 3.5 tonnes but not more
so mobile home manufacturers have
shifted to new lighter materials
melendez assorted kim blur hi murs
managing director says that
three-quarters of campers on the market
are now under three and a half tons and
heimer expects lighter caravans to
increase their share of the market even
further especially because of the
driver's license situation but also
because of tolls and because some cities
no longer allow vehicles weighing more
than 3.5 tons to enter to reduce the
campers weight heimer revised the door
handles cupboard doors and floors to
include lightweight materials the
slender two point 22 meter width and a
light just under seven meters also save
weight and make the large vehicle a bit
more maneuverable but the starting price
of at least eighty three thousand euros
hasn't been trimmed
well North cool Martha's concludes by
pointing out how much storage space the
heimer b-class ass even calls it a
garage after all it has space for a
couple of bicycles or even motorcycles
oh god no toilet I dimake Sunday stands
for nice price dependable cars although
not says our car review or Sasha for
exciting ones the car maker set out to
change that image in 2013 with a coupe a
version for the i30 but it didn't really
set automotive hearts on fire not least
because of the engines available at the
time they've now been upgraded as part
of a facelift Sasha recalls Hyundai and
joined perhaps the ultimate accolade for
the regular I 30 Martin Winterkorn then
CEO of the Volkswagen Group nice and
smooth the coop a edition of that top
selling Hyundai was created at its
European design and development center
in whistles I'm it comes with three
gasoline and two diesel engines we
checked out the most powerful diesel
version with a direct shift gearbox
official fuel consumption is four point
two liters for 100 kilometers sasha is
driving the 110 kilowatt diesel version
even if the specs don't quite seem to
work out in reality this engine together
with a dual clutch transmission give you
a certain flow bordering on the sporty
the trick is not to fully depress the
gas if you do the transmission will just
shift down three speeds and the engine
will get hysterical if you only push the
pedal two-thirds of the way down the
transmission will gradually shift
upwards and you can really enjoy it li
ste students all on the Holden Vic women
Cletus pasta boy
the facelift of the facelift was
primarily on the technical front explain
Sasha there's an array of assist
features including a park assist it
costs extra so Sasha wants to see if
it's worth it definitely gonna cook my
pasta at Silicon it's activated at the
push of a button the system then tells
the driver what to do or rather what not
to do you do have to keep to a snail's
pace otherwise the car will turn off the
assist parking is pretty straightforward
even for beginners and the system is
very intuitive that said it takes a lot
more than two moves the i30 likes to be
precise and therefore takes its time
the pocket in the assist is only truly
helpful if you're a really poor Parker
reckon Sasha and on city streets other
road users might get a bit impatient so
you might find them getting a little hot
under the collar and the assist only
works when parallel parking for all
other forms of parking spaces you have
to guide the vehicle in yourself once
you've found and taken a space watch
your doors in the new i30 Kupe there's
17 centimeters longer than with the
regular version that makes getting into
the rear seats easier but when you're
getting out the door swings out further
so sasha is now going to repark the
thing pockets on the mole it's easier
when there are no cars next to you of
course
oh yes absolutely so now even sasha has
enough space to take a seat and the rear
the idea so nice little entry could be
more elegant but you do have a
relatively generous amount of space both
legroom and Headroom and the safety belt
holder is a nice touch to invited longer
doors mean the b-pillar is so far back
that you'd otherwise have to lean a long
way behind yourself to build up an
Elijah itself infants they would coolest
whats coop the coop hey matches the
cargo space of the regular five-door
edition 378 liters just two liters less
than a gulf and when you fold down the
rear bench it increases to 1316 leaders
the COO pays front is based structure
late on the five-door edition which you
can see and that affiliation has its
benefits the 5-door version got a five
star rating for the Euro NCAP crash test
so occupants of the three door model
also enjoy maximum protection from a
head-on collision
there's little change in the interior
and why should there be nice and smooth
the workmanship is very satisfactory
everywhere
miss lemon the former VW bosh was right
nice and smooth and that also applies to
the facelift it's not quite as exciting
as Hyundai might have wished but it is a
solid package and those are the
qualities that appeal the customers
Coonans their good uncle
in 1984 Spanish car maker say OTT
released their first car as an
independent company the abita while the
automotive industry boomed in much of
post-second World War Europe Spain
lagged far behind I see Alison as our
tester Kristin Bauer explains in the
1950s when say I was founded Spain was
really a developing country in terms of
its automotive industry the streets worn
for condition cars a luxury restricted
to the upper class and buses the most
common form of transport but that soon
changed in 1953 the first seeit left the
production line at the zona franca
factory in barcelona see ott was still a
state-owned company and until the 1980s
have produced only Fiat models under
licence the very first say out was the
1400 a midsize sedan followed by the
1500 see I produced a whole range of
Fiat derivatives including one of its
most popular cars the sea at six hundred
and the Panda in the 1980s in 1984 the
newly independent seeit released the
ibiza with it's very own stylings
including a black radiator grille and
black bumpers
the airport or Christophe says the
prototype a pizza was called the s-1 as
in number one saya a name that signifies
a radical new beginning independence
from Fiat gave saya a blank slate in
Barcelona the finished product was then
crowned Ibiza after the balearic island
which laid the foundations for all
future say odd names each further
vehicle was named after a spanish city
or region like cordoba mobilya and al
hombre hang on isn't alamba a fort
christophe ass well it still sounds good
which probably wouldn't be the case in
germany their shrine fort rüsselsheim
with castro walsall not quite so sexy
thanked me so sexy after it split from
Fiat in 1981 see outside the production
agreement with Volkswagen in 1986 say I
was incorporated into the VW Group and
after 10 years of scrabbling in the dirt
these Spanish car makers were back in
the black somebody in victim with
Christophe explains that during the
beaches development say I'd received
massive support from across Europe the
design came from Italy the bodywork
concept from german manufacturer carmen
and osnabrück and the engine from
portion stood guard porsche also
fine-tuned the chassis making itza a
real gem of its class with excellent
role holding and performance that it
couldn't be really proud of Christoph's
1.2 liter model with 71 horsepower has a
top speed of 158 km/h
the CIT beats ax was the most advanced
compact car of its time
scit bit size Christa thinks the sanity
beat says an archetypal modern compact
car small but roomy it's exactly the
same length as the VW Polo of the time
with roughly the same wheelbase as the
Gulf mk2 and the result extremely short
overhangs at the front and back
providing extra space inside for
passengers and luggage
this angular hatchback was originally
available as a three-door model only but
the five-door followed in 1986 granted
some vintage car lovers would say it's
not much to look at but the first Ibiza
has gone on to become a vintage classic
and a testimony to the no-frills 80s
the interior is just as roomy and
comfortable as higher classification
vehicles but the plastic fittings give
it a rather underclass feel by decency a
deep it's 100 sq this Ibiza was released
in 1991 Christophe explains after it had
undergone a facelift the new version at
different bumpers white turn indicators
and this unusual plastic covering for
the radiator grille which Christophe
didn't think much of time to take a look
under the hood this is a four-cylinder
engine from Porsche had a choice of
reputation of being maneuverable sporty
and efficient and of course Porsches
signature adds extra panache can an
extra cost to see out though the license
for each engine with a Porsche logo
rancy at seven Deutsche marks it tends
to be a fun day mark but but it's a
sound investment for the customer and
probably the cheapest way to drive a
Porsche of sorts plus it
the 1.2 litre 71 horsepower engine gave
the car respectable performance for the
time at a meager 890 kilograms the first
sayati beats await as much as a modern
smart car and say it soon smoothed out
any teething problems it had with
quality control during early production
yes he had Christophe reckons the CIT
beats it was a car ahead of its time
built with love and a joy to drive and
it increased its export rate by
seventy-six percent of course not many
cars had been sold abroad before that
but this success made it an attractive
brand and in 1986 Volkswagen took over
the company and so this say at ibiza is
not just the first it's the only genuine
seeit because the second-generation
starting in 1993 was based entirely on
the VW Polo and it was definitely a
Volkswagens baby what that tastes like
fun foil sock with over 5 million
vehicles produced the sea at ibiza has
long been Spain's best-selling car even
today the sporty dynamic little car is a
big hit with young drivers
you